une europe pour une fois unis et
coordonnée quelques jours après le feu
vert de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments aux vaccins pfizer biotech
c'est une grande partie des états
membres qui ont entamé simultanément
leurs campagnes de vaccination ce week
end en italie pays le plus touché
d'europe avec 71 1000 décès la première
dose du vaccin a été injectée peu avant
8 heures sur une infirmière claudia
l'hiver ni ni il a été douloureux
d'assister aux défaites que ce virus a
causé
mais aujourd'hui on est conscient que
c'est un jour important et décisif
la science et la médecine sont les seuls
moyens avec le sens civique de chacun
qui nous permettront de sortir gagnant
de cette dure bataille
je le dis du fond du coeur vaccinons
nous une heure plus tard c'est une femme
de 96 ans qui était la première personne
vaccinée d'espagne dans une maison de
retraite du centre du pays l'allemagne
la hongrie et la slovaquie avait déjà
ouvert la voie à la veille
en commençant leur campagne de
vaccination avec un jour d'avancé sur le
lancement officiel européen
certains dirigeants ont même donné
l'exemple ce dimanche le ministre de la
santé bulgare a reçu la première dose
dans son pays en grèce c'est le premier
ministre qui s'est vu inoculer le vaccin
aujourd'hui est un grand jour pour la
science mais aussi pour l'union
européenne qui a réussi à fournir le
vaccin le même jour à tous les pays
européens
appliquant ainsi le message de
solidarité européenne un message de
solidarité du nom
les premières doses du vaccin fighter
biotech avait été livrée simultanément
samedi à l'ensemble des états de l'union
européenne
les pays membres ont négocié ensemble
les approvisionnements auprès des
fournisseurs avec une répartition en
fonction de la population
l'ensemble des états européens ont aussi
posé des options afin de disposer de
suffisamment de vaccins pour vacciner là
totalité de leurs populations en 2021
cette campagne européenne coordonnée a
été saluée par de nombreux dirigeants
européens dont emmanuel macron et bien
sûr par ses représentants
nous sommes bien préparés nous avons
élaboré une stratégie européenne commune
de vaccination
cela montre une fois de plus crédible et
érable d'apprendre à 27 ans enfin plutôt
que de faire cavalier seul
une unité qui n'a pas toujours été au
rendez vous l'accord autour du plan de
relance européen avait mis plusieurs
semaines avant de voir le jour dans un
premier temps en europe comme ailleurs
les différentes campagnes de
vaccinations porteront sur de faibles
effectifs de personnes âgées et fragiles
le nombre de lots disponibles dans le
monde reste pour le moment réduit